et acharné pour combien de temps encore
dans ce complexe sidérurgique de Mario
Paul c'est ici que son retranché depuis
plusieurs jours les irréductibles
combattants Ukrainiens l'un d'entre eux
commandant de la 36e brigade de marine
lance aujourd'hui cet appel désespéré
nous vivons peut-être nos derniers jours
voir nos dernières heures
l'ennemi est dix fois plus nombreux que
nous
l'armée russe à l'avantage dans les airs
en artillerie en force terrestre
nous appelons les dirigeants du monde
entier à nous aider
un millier de civils serait également
prise au piège dans l'enfer de cette
usine à siéger la télévision russe
diffuse ces images d'habitants épuisées
il viendrait d’évacuer la zone grâce à
un corridor humanitaire pour la première
fois depuis samedi Moscou et Kiev ont
trouvé un accord pour permettre
l'évacuation des civils mais la joie au
maire de Mario Paul reste sceptique
je suis sûr que la Russie ne respectera
pas sa parole
ce serait bien si les Russes laissaient
les habitants quitter la zone de l'usine
où la ville
50 jours
pourquoi le ferait-il maintenant
la Russie a entamé hier une nouvelle
phase de son offensive dans l'est de
l'Ukraine Mario Paul la résistante est
l'une des villes qu'elle veut faire
tomber militaire et autorité ukrainien
réclame des armes supplémentaires aux
pays alliés